شريف بن سلمان مع كل الجمهوريين تبقى
رسائل الحزب واضحه لقعدته الانتخابيه منع
الاجهاض التضخم والاقتصاد الباهت وارتفاع
نسبه الجريمه بالاضافه الى شخص الرئيس
جوبيدا
بالنسبه للحزب القديم العظيم كما يسمى هنا
قد لا يكون اسم ترامب مدرجا في بطاقه
الاقتراع لهذا العام ولكن الترامبيه او ما
يعرف بالماجا موجوده بشكل واضح
[موسيقى]
من الانجازات العظيمه عندما كان رئيسا
واعتقد انه اذا ما اعيد انتخابه مره جديده
فسيكون بامكانه تحقيق الكثير
تريوكي
الحزب الجمهوري هو
85% ترامب
الرئيس السابق اختار بنفسه مرشح مجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي الخبير الطبيه الشهيره
الدكتور
[تصفيق]
اليمنيه المتطرف لمنصب الحاكم بعد فوزه
المفاجئ في الانتخابات التمهيديه
ليله السيده فوزي
[تصفيق]
2021 على الكونغرس ولعب دورا رئيسيا في
الجهود المبذوله لالغاء نتائج 2020 في
ولايه بنسلفانيا واذا ما فاز بمنصب الحاكم
فسيكون لديه سلطه كبيره في تنفيذ انتخابات
الولايه
الذهاب والاستمتاع بحياته بعد التقاعد
ولكنه يحب ويهتم كثيرانيا فترشح لمنصب
حاكم الولايه هو قائد بالفطره
ليله انتخابات في بنسلفانيا خاصيه مهمه من
الممكن ان تعتمد الغالبيه في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي عليها في الولايات المعروفه
بمراكز التجمع السكانيه الكبرى وبصناعاتها
الاخذه في التدهور يحاول الجمهوريون ان
يستغل الوضع الاقتصادي واخفاقات بعيدا في
هذا المجال بالاضافه الى موضوع الاجهاض
وارتفاع نسبه الجريمه مواضيعه تهم الناخبه
في الريف المحافظ تاريخيا
زيت سليمان العربيه